mark he's wired in sorry he's wired in
is he yes
how about now you're still wired in
security you wish for 24 million new
shares of stock
you were told that if new investors come
your shares diluted how much for his
what was mr zuckerberg's ownership share
diluted down to
it wasn't what was mr moskovitz's
ownership share diluted down to
it wasn't what was sean parker's
ownership share diluted down to
it wasn't what was peter thiel's
ownership share diluted down to it
wasn't and what was your ownership share
diluted down to
point zero three percent
[Music]
you signed the papers you set me up
you're gonna blame me because you were
the business head of the company and you
made a bad business deal with your own
companies it's gonna be like i'm not a
part of facebook it won't be like you're
not a part of facebook you're not a part
of facebook my name's on the masthead
you might want to check again just
because i froze the account you think we
were going to let you parade around in
your ridiculous suits pretending you
were running this sorry my prod isn't
the cleaners along with my hoodie and my
[ __ ] flip-flops you pretentious
douchebag security's here you'll be
leaving now i'm not signing those papers
we will get the signature
tell me this isn't about me getting into
the phoenix
you
you did it i knew you did it you planted
that story about the chicken i didn't
plant the story about what's he talking
about have me accused of animal cruelty
seriously what the hell's the chicken
and i'll bet what you hated the most is
that they identified me as a co-founder
of facebook which i am you better lawyer
up [ __ ] cause i'm not coming back for
thirty
30
i'm coming back for everything
get him out of here it's okay
hang on
i almost forgot
here's your 19 000 i wouldn't cash it
though i drew it on the account you
froze
i like sitting next to you sean
it makes me look so tough